Sabrina Spellman is back to raise hell in
Greendale and uncover the secret truth about
herself in Part 2 of her Chilling Adventures.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm explaining everything you need
to know about the second season of Chilling
Adventures of Sabrina, the hidden clues you
missed in the episode finale, and what to
look forward to in Season 3.
Of course, there'll be spoilers, so take care
if you're not all caught up.
The second season of Chilling Adventures finally
reveals Sabrina's true parentage.
As she goes to confront Lucifer who's risen
from Hell into Greendale, he reveals that
he, the Dark Lord, is Sabrina's father.
It's a Darth Vader-esque moment as Sabrina
learns her real feather is the big bad and
she's not the half-witch, half-mortal she
always thought she was.
Sabrina's conception and birth are a twist
on the biblical story of Mary and Joseph where
it was the Holy Spirit, not Joseph, who conceived
the baby Jesus in Mary.
Biblical references abound throughout this
season with the first episode starting with
a dream Sabrina has of her birth which is
reminiscent of traditional Christian nativity
scenes.
The episode is called The Epiphany with the
Three Kings of Hell, an obvious play on the
3 Wise Men or Kings who visit Jesus.
As Ambrose explains in the finale, the Dark
Lord's plan "in siring a babe of a witch,
mortal, and infernal blood" is to pervert
the Holy Trinity.
Before this revelation, incredible powers
that Sabrina never knew she had are gradually
unveiled.
In the sixth episode during the witch-hunters'
attack, they place a crown of thorns on her
head and pierce her body three times with
crossbow arrows, evoking parallels with Christ's
crucifixion.
Sabrina dies but is resurrected, like Christ,
and then as she levitates with hands ablaze,
she sets the witch hunters on fire in a scene
that reminded me of the end of the first season
when Sabrina summoned hellfire against the
Greendale 13, becoming only the fourth witch
in history to ever achieve that.
She is even able to resurrect Melvin and Elspeth
who the witch hunters had murdered.
"You're not a witch.
What are you?"
"I am the Dark Lord's sword!"
From Sabrina's words, it's clear that these
amazing powers stem from her infernal blood
or conception by the Dark Lord.
Harvey also points out to Sabrina that she
resembles Jean Grey with her phoenix powers
in this scene:
"Jean Grey was this really powerful mutant.
When she was on the verge of death something
saved her."
Like Sabrina, when Jean Grey had access to
the Phoenix Force, her power levels went insane
and there were even instances where the force
brought the dead back to life.
These miracles are explored in more detail
in the seventh episode with further parallels
being drawn between Sabrina and Jesus.
Sabrina restores Roz's sight by getting her
to wash her eyes, in a miracle not dissimilar
to how Jesus gave sight to a blind man when
he ordered him to go wash in a pool of water.
Sabrina's devilish DNA seems to give her powers
unavailable to her witch brethren.
And initially, in her often impetuous way,
she assumes there's no downside to these almost
unlimited abilities, much to the consternation
of her aunt Hilda.
"Everything has a price.
That's how witchcraft works."
"But I don't think there's a price for me.
Not anymore.
I think I've tapped into a different kind
of magic.
One that isn't based on cause and effect.
It feels different."
"You are racking up a cosmic debt the like
of which the world's never seen."
As Sabrina's friends later discover, her display
of extraordinary powers is actually a harbinger
of a dreadful future.
The mosaic they discover in the Greendale
mines shows that the Dark Lord plans for Sabrina
to be the Herald of Hell, in other words,
the bringer of the Apocalypse.
After Lucifer arrives in Greendale, he orders
Sabrina to blow the horn of Gabriel and open
the gates of Hell so the VIPs of the underworld
can attend her coronation as their Queen.
Lilith, who has served the Dark Lord all this
time in the belief that she would be the one
ascending to the throne, decides she's fed
up of being constantly cast aside by Lucifer.
We do see a slightly softer side to Madam
Satan when she meets Ms Wardwell's boyfriend
Adam and discovers the possibility of a loving
relationship.
But when the Dark Lord finds out about Lilith's
secret relationship, he cruelly kills Adam
and serves him up on a platter.
So by the time of the finale, when Lucifer
rejects Lilith again, she decides to team
up with Sabrina and the Spellmans to defeat
the Dark Lord.
After a failed attempt to kill Lucifer in
the woods, they concoct a different scheme
to entrap him in the Acheron Configuration
that held the sleep demon Batibat.
Sabrina and the coven put on a masquerade
dance and Sabrina then captures Lucifer in
Edward Spellman's Acheron, however, it doesn't
hold for long and the devil breaks out.
When Lilith explains that the only prison
stronger than the Acheron is the human body,
Nick Scratch offers himself as a host body
to keep Lucifer imprisoned.
Nick, who's studied Edward's teachings, says
he's "the best binder and conjuror since Edward
Spellman" and believes he's the only one strong
enough to contain the devil.
And so Nick Scratch becomes the devil himself,
something that's always been hinted at in
his name as "Old Nick" and "Old Scratch" are
nicknames for the Devil.
Nick's actions are also a way for him to redeem
himself for secretly betraying Sabrina to
the Dark Lord.
By the way, a nice detail in this scene and
episode is the name of the dance that Sabrina
and Lucifer perform at the masquerade, The
Mephisto Waltz, which is also the name of
a 1971 horror movie about Satanists and body
swapping.
And after Lucifer is defeated, Lilith finally
gets the job she's been wanting forever: Queen
of Hell.
She takes Nick's body down with her to make
sure Lucifer doesn't escape.
Before she leaves, though, she restores Sabrina's
"witch abilities".
"So now, my dear, you have both power and
freedom.
And may you never give up either again."
It's unclear at this point if these include
the full powers we saw on display that came
from her infernal heritage or if it's just
regular witch powers.
CAOS Season 2 doesn't just overturn the established
order in the underworld.
When Lucifer meets with Father Blackwood,
the Dark Lord mocks the new Church of Judas
that Blackwood has imposed on the Greendale
coven.
In fact, Lucifer orders Blackwood to bow down
to Sabrina, telling him his church must report
to her.
Blackwood is furious, as he knows Sabrina
is opposed to the misogynist and regressive
rules he's enforced in the church, plus he
also plotted to kill Sabrina and her family
including Ambrose.
Blackwood is so enraged that, rather than
hand power over the coven to Sabrina, he poisons
them all except his daughter Prudence and
his twins.
Prudence is horrified by this and his plans
to continue the Blackwood line by marrying
his twins to each other and, with the help
of the Spellmans, they manage to save Agatha,
Dorcas and some of the other witches and warlocks.
We also discovered this season, as many of
us already suspected, that Blackwood was responsible
for engineering the plane crash that killed
Edward and Diana Spellman.
The irony for Blackwood is that despite his
efforts to block Edward Spellman's reforms,
one of the tenets from Spellman's manifesto
has now become a reality; that "all witches
must be revered as the matriarchs of the Church
of Night."
So with Blackwood's departure, Zelda has now
become the Church's High Priestess.
Blackwood's future looks bleak, with a vengeful
Prudence and Ambrose ready to hunt him down
next season with swords and crossbows.
Signalling that Blackwood's reign over their
Church is over, Prudence decapitates the Judas
statue he installed at the academy, possibly
also foreshadowing her father's eventual fate.
I also wonder whether there'll be any long-lasting
effects from the Ring a Ring o' Roses incantation
that the Weird Sisters were performing.
In modern times, the traditional rhyming song
has been associated with the plague and we
did briefly see Blackwood's nose bleeding
while the sisters were singing it.
Whether there'll be any lasting ill effects
on Blackwood though remains to be seen.
With Sabrina clearer about her origins and
future now, she's much freer to spend more
time with her mortal friends Harvey, Roz and
Theo who were often off doing their own thing
by themselves in Part 2.
In fact, Sabrina recognises that the trio
managed to keep the demonic hordes at bay
by themselves when they held the gates of
Hell closed; so she realises she doesn't need
to protect them all the time.
Indeed, Sabrina suggests they team up for
what Harvey calls the Fright Club.
And Sabrina comes up with their first mission
which is to go to Hell and bring Nick back.
Now, that sounds like it could be fun, but
it seems pretty likely that something will
go wrong and Lucifer will end up escaping.
And although Lilith has gone to hell, thankfully
we'll still be seeing actress Michelle Gomez
on the show as the original Ms Wardwell is
back, so we'll be finding out if she suffered
any side effects from Lilith inhabiting her
body.
Sabrina also mentioned she's going to look
into her mother's side of the family.
That could be really interesting especially
if the other baby we saw at Sabrina's birth
isn't just symbolic of her dual nature but
is actually a secret twin!
Until we find out, I've got a theory video
on all the possibilities which you should
check out by tapping in the top right or click
the link in the video description.
So, what did you think of Sabrina Season 2?
And do you have any theories or ideas on what
you'd like to see next season?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below.
For more deep dives like this into your favourite
TV shows, subscribe and hit the bell to get
all my new videos.
If you enjoyed this, tap left to watch my
Sabrina twin theory video or tap right for
another video you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!